my father's nickname for me was the
brave one growing up and he said I was
born with a fist up in the air and that
I was ready to fight injustice wherever
it happened and usually I was after him
usually I was like dad yeah that kind of
thing it's the book is it's about a lot
of things it's about my life and it's
about helping to get people brave and
it's not about me - it predates that but
it's it's I'm really proud of it you
towards the hardback when it came out
last year is anything different one year
on as you go around venues and speak to
people very much so I felt I've met so
many survivors and people that now when
it first came out me too was really
kicking off and so most of the questions
I was getting was about that right and
and my book and my movement my message
is really one of bravery and just trying
to be more socially conscious I think me
too pushed a great cultural reset on the
world but as far as it being attributed
to being a movement I think that makes
it sound like there's women in the
streets as pitchforks running after men
and that's that's really not the case
and my book and my message is all about
humanity I'm Pro man I'm Pro women and
Pro everybody and I'm Pro us being
better and you talked about in your book
series of cults this cult that you were
born into an extraordinary childhood
that you had you talk about the cults of
Hollywood and and you describe it as the
way sort of a story if the way that you
fought your way out and you hope that
you can inspire other people tell us how
you fought your way out at the cult of
Hollywood well I was doing a movie for
Quentin Tarantino and I it was as if I
had this like alarm bell going off in my
head saying wake up rose wake up rose
and I was so deeply unhappy in my life
and I couldn't figure out what it was
that was making me unhappy and I
realized it was kind of all of it
because I'd adhered to the rules of
Hollywood for so long and those rules
are an illusion and Hollywood gives us a
really narrow mirror to view ourselves
in and it's it's kind of one-dimensional
but it affects so many and it is a form
of propaganda and way sort of sexism are
we talking about it's sort of not just
sexism it's like hey here's what you are
as a man
what your as a woman here's what you are
as a transgender here's what you are as
anything and the problem is is that it's
96% men and the Directors Guild that's
all the directors and that statistic
hasn't changed since 1946 so it's just a
very narrow view and and it operates you
know Hollywood operates in secrecy not a
lot of people know what really goes on
there it's kind of you know it's an
illusion really it's like it's supposed
to be glamorous supposed to be all these
things and behind the scenes that can be
really tragic and really traumatic
it can also be great but for me I was
discovered so I was never trying to be
an actress and and it was it was a it
was a hard road so do you consider
yourself now on the outside looking in
at that industry and I'm intrigued as to
what you think of the people who are
inside that industry I I'm definitely on
the outside looking in whereas before I
was both a person in society on the
outside and also very much on the inside
but I what do I think about it I think
they're really fear-based and I I wish
they'd be braver but I understand why
they're not in what way there's still a
lot of stuff that goes on there that
hasn't been uncovered and it's not just
about sexual harassment it's about abuse
of power and and it's about how you know
that town is flooded Los Angeles
Hollywood with with young beautiful
people year after year after year are
coming to realize their dreams and my
message is one that you don't have to be
hurt to realize your dreams you don't
need to be degraded to realize your
dreams and I don't have the most respect
for Hollywood I can't say that I think
it's a great place but I do think since
the influences the world so much and it
is America's number one export I do
believe it should be better and it's
incumbent on itself to be better and you
had first-hand experience of that sexual
abuse and that abuse of power in
Hollywood tell us about that
well it was a very traumatic period in
my life and I'm somebody I talk about
this in my book I was homeless when I
was 13 I was a runaway and I was so
proud of myself for not getting
assaulted when I was on the street
it's a strange thing to be proud of but
I was very proud of that and then when I
thought my life was changing and getting
easier then it happened to me and it
shouldn't have I was in the middle of my
second film for my attacker and I know
you have to say alleged alleged there we
go but it's true and in it it had
disastrous consequences not just for my
career but for my personal well-being
and it's something that it changes who
you are and it steals who you are and
who you're meant to be and it's deeply
unfair you described Harvey Weinstein
you but you don't name him you call him
the monster it's one chapter of your
book I think that that particular point
in your life it's more you know your
life is much more than that obviously
but describing him in that ways why did
you take that decision to do that and
not name him and make that distinction I
had help
setting up the New York Times article
that came out so I knew he was going to
be named and I didn't want I didn't want
his ugly name in my pretty book I didn't
want it there and and I've seen him he's
been the monster on my back for so many
years I mean as a person who hired
ex-mossad agents to steal 125 pages of
my book before it came out there was a
million dollar bounty on my book they
infiltrated my life pretending to be
sexual assault survivors it's just so
much insanity trying to control what he
has proclivities I wonder how you feel
more than 80 women have accused him
Harvey Weinstein of different things
sexual misconduct
he's currently facing criminal charges
on five kinds of sexual abuse as you
said charges he denies I read an
interview with you that said you place
little faith in the justice system he's
going on trial in New York later this
week why is that logic I feel very rich
and powerful people have they do have a
different set of rules in the justice
system than other people do and I and I
I am cautiously optimistic but very
cautiously optimistic I know what
happened I know he's guilty and if
that's all I'll ever get two halves and
that's all I and his other survivors
will ever get to have but
it is something at least that he's going
to court and that there is public
scrutiny involved in this and that that
is his because crime will be known in
your book you state that you want to be
known as a survivor not as a victim and
that that is very important to you but
do you still feel that to this day
you're still suffering as a result of
abuses that have happened during your
life I know I am suffering to this day
but I also live a great life you know
but it's been a hard hard fight to have
my own narrative out there because for
so long he paid off people in the media
to slander me for years and years
because they never signed a
confidentiality agreement and so I
presented a danger and for me it's just
been about having a healthy and balanced
life while living in a very
extraordinary extreme situation but when
you push at power power pushes back can
I ask you about the meatsuit movement
and the times up movement cuz you you
make a pretty clear distinction between
the two and it's fair to say that you
the time's up movement you've been
pretty critical of lily-livered and far
too liberal and actors in Hollywood is
that something you stand by today and
you think that it's two-faced is that a
way to put it I hope it's not I hope
time's up does great work I don't really
know what they have done but I hope
they've done good work I wish the best
for them and I hope they're brave and I
hope they're not lily-livered but I
don't think wearing a bunch of black
dresses to the Oscars I don't know if
there's any kind of major movement that
will be solved by dresses no and I think
there's again it's self policing and it
shouldn't be just the women doing this
it should be everybody me too
you know the press really calls it a
movement but I feel that it was more
offal way for people to communicate did
this happen to me too that's all it
really is and the press kind of made it
sound like there's you know thousands of
women in the streets with pitchforks
running after men and I don't think
that's the case it's not about that and
men get hurt too I was gonna do you
think men think that of the movement and
are hostile towards it you know last
night I met a lovely young man
he was probably about 25 and he said
thank you it's changed the way my
friends and I talked to each other so it
does have boots on the ground it's just
again it's a reset it's to see things
through different eyes let's to see each
other's human and not as a gender and I
think we might actually be able to solve
this if we can do that you know wearing
black dresses may as he say be a PR
exercise with some people getting on a
bandwagon but if it raises the profile
of abuse in whatever form it may take
do you think that there is general
appetite in society to address these
issues we've seen recent documentaries
for example into our Kelly and historic
allegations there which I should say he
also is denying Michael Jackson this
week a two-part documentaries come out
raising questions again about his
conduct with with children when he was
still alive and those have got to be
positives that have come out of this
they are positive and you know it's hard
for society it's hard for me it's hard
for probably you know you to to hear
this stuff and and to have your hero's
punctured it's brutal you know Michael
Jackson was the first poster I ever had
on my wall I love Michael Jackson but we
need to have a more nuanced conversation
about this and sometimes the growth is
it hurts you know when you're a little
your legs hurt but you got taller right
I think that's kind of a society has
been going through it's it's a growth
spurt and and like I said growth can
often be really challenging and ugly and
we have to face the ugliness if we're
gonna heal this wound in society I do
wonder if any of your events or when
you're doing activist work when it comes
to things like that holding power to
account and particularly accusations of
sexual abuse with all the men that we've
mentioned today there was no article and
this is you know I think it's fair to
say not a you know a major majority view
but there is a real strand of opinion
that says allegations are treated as
facts these days Michael Jackson's case
it would lead to his music being banned
and someone writing a piece saying in
the me to ear we know presumed guilt
instead of innocence if people it talks
that you give or that you speak to say
that to what's your response I do think
there should we do process and I believe
our Kelly for instance is going to that
due process
I believe Harvey Weinstein is going
through that due process you know
Michael Jackson is dead so he can't go
through that due process but he did
before and he was declared innocent you
know it's it's it's hard it's it's a
really it's a it's a tough thing I think
the reason is presumed guilt is because
we all know so much of this goes on and
that it's not hard to believe right
that's what's that's what's so hard
about it but I also think that's not
necessarily the healthiest view either
sometimes when culture shifts it goes
too far in one direction and then it
finds its way to the middle and I think
that's hopefully what we're gonna be
doing we're on a journey back to the
middle have we gone too far one way is
that what you're saying lord I think
we've gone too far I think it's it's
just scary I think it scares a lot of
people and it's scary to talk about
stuff that society didn't talk about
before and if we did it was more to skin
you know a woman's complaint but I know
so many men who've been abused and her
and and they deserve to have their voice
heard too it's it's a complex situation
there's no one easy answer and every
situation is different but I hope that
for the people that are out there that
do abuse power they will think
differently
I think serial predators are going to be
serial predators because I don't think
that they have normal brains but the
ones that are the lower level offenders
I hope they'll see their way to a better
way of being and living let's talk about
International Women's Day I mean all
over the globe today their slogan is
balance for better and I just wonder
what that represents to you well I
suppose balance for better represents
equality I mean that's really simply
what it is when people you know call me
a feminist I'm like okay I'm a FEMINIST
because I'm not stupid if you believe in
equal pay and equal rights
congratulations you too are a feminist
that's basically all it really means to
me and and I think that women you know
it's been a long road it's been a long
road but again I think if women and they
should be celebrated I think men should
be celebrated I think everybody should
be celebrated it's nice to have a day
isn't it yeah it's not our one day